jessie j avais toi ça très content de te
voir graphe longtemps je m'en rappelle
et c'est moi qui avais commenter
l'eurovision
ouais je tique jeu qui fait tache en son
temps c'est pile maca main je te le dis
ils recevraient et j'adore ce que tu
faisais donc très bien mais j'ai si
c'est bon je comprends pas tu as
participé à et si on se rencontre et
ouais mes frères toi t'es pas là si on
se rencontre et moi je te rends compte
je le paie sodiac du mois contraire dit
moi alors et si on te rencontrer céder
sur m6 et une demie la mission préféré
c'est vrai moi j'adore je suis comme un
fou
il taperait tu t'apprêtes à rencontrer
pour la première fois sofia c'est ça une
fille avec qui tu discuter sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis plusieurs mois
at-on là et si tu en train meilleur que
toi tu es célibataire
ouais et mathieu cuisine ouais la vie
est mal faite savait pas non mais c'est
fou le gars côté de toi et de 18 femmes
non mais voit pas de mère d'un ami
simmons & simmons et c'est un bon pote
c'est vrai ça m'aurait pas écoutée voyez
comme pourboire de destins différents
si ça vous faire l'amour à jesse
commencé que tu trouves pas l'amour je
comprends pas khutba les aléas je sais
pas je ne sais pas je sais pas le
prendre c'est que les gens ils pensent
que quand tu es en partie sous danseurs
aux autres ouais je pense que t'as pas
de kurt est un robot que tout vient
comme ça tu sais quoi que tu dois faire
peur n'est pas sérieux bah oui mais
parce que t'es trop beau goss freire
non mais c'est avec gilles on dit pas du
tout ça c'est un vrai frère mois suite à
neuf on en rigolait tu des charges
telles pajiba pechoux la boulangère ces
deux minutes avant ça c'était avant
avant j'étais avant et arrière moi
j'étais vraiment rebondi là c'est bon je
me suis pas envie de te caser sa femme
ont déjà que j'ai envie de marquer je
suis à laurière tactique avec sofia
ouais regarder le portrait de celui-ci
mais la peur de ça d'ailleurs d'accord
de chabal a peur bas mais trop beau son
visage vous dit peut-être quelque chose
c'est normal puisqu'il est connu sous le
nom de jessy matador
l'ifop
sa notoriété elle a beaucoup aidé à
séduire si j'avais pas tes artistes
je pense que 98% des pharmas qui j'étais
j'aurais peut être avec elle je
m'appelle une fois j'ai dit quoi bon je
vais créer un événement pour qu'elles
viennent chez moi j'ai fait un brunch
étouffé m me dis ouais je viens je viens
je viens mais elle est pas venu on de se
voir après apprenants elle est annulée
qu'est ce qui lui fait peur il fait que
je suis connue
vous le faites que j'ai connu beaucoup
de femmes dans le passé opinant sont
aujourd'hui j'ai besoin de savoir si tu
as besoin de savoir un éclairage je sais
pas si des sites a connu beaucoup de
femmes dans ta vie ta jamais été mariés
si j'ai démarré pendant deux ans
d'accord un très bon salaire mais c'est
normal
si je veux dire après parfois les les
chemins se séparent c'est comme ça une
déviation et puis avec à 8 millions de
personnes qui vivent une relation
passionnée sans jamais se voir
non et puis et puis on avance dans le
virtuel plus justement c'est compliqué
d'assumer le réel c'est à une
appréhension parce que c'est un cocon en
fait exactement ça qu'est-ce qui n'ont
non je pense pas comme dragon ensuite on
dit maintenant juste non je suis une
personne assez soft
oui non vous cherchez quoi vous
[Rires]
sur ses toiles or ici mais bon c'est
encore curieux voilà c'est encore
curieux bon dieu si vous êtes déjà fait
poser un lapin une première fois par
sofia way qui devait venir chez vous
mais qui vous a planté au dernier moment
et du coup lors du tournage d'une
émission vous avez une petite vanne et
vous a fait croire qu'elle ne serait pas
là et si on se rencontrait j'adore il se
il se découvre sur les réseaux sociaux
et après il se voit tu as vu vraiment
coup de coeur ouais franchement mieux
parce qu'après c'est vrai que moi à ce
moment-là quand on se presse sur les
réseaux c'était premier confinement moi
j'étais blessé non j'en suis fait
rupture tendon d'achille en dansant en
fait
mais oui mais tu danses trop jeu tous
les deux grosses tendances en a peut
être épuisés étaient baissées j'avais
les pieds comme ça chez moi tout seul
donc c'était compliqué beaucoup sur mon
téléphone donc on s'est connus comme ça
on revient sur ses shows au 6 juin a mis
un jour qui a eu un panaris aujourd'hui
ah les deux parties je sais que la main
ici elle peut pas les rater gym à pavie
on va c'est voir ici
[Musique]
soso ça va je l'étais un peu c'est que
je suis désolé je m'excuse je vais pas
dire d'accord à coutens je suis dégoûté
[Musique]
c'est que ces quelques plaintes on veut
boussole mêlant des civils est énorme
alors et à ma mère qui m'écrit pourquoi
tu tiens les fiches de casta voilà je
n'y vois là bas s'il s'agit de ma
meilleure voie là bas j'ai de ma mère
donc voilà donc si ça gêne ma meilleure
voilà oui comment ça il va dissoudre
otage les et on m'a jamais parlé comme
ça maintenant je vais parler de j6m
alors c'est vrai que cette émission moi
le moi j'adore quand tu l'as vue est-ce
que tu as eu un terrain proche
moi quand même quand même moi quand même
quand même moi oui jeanne mas non cette
émission parce qu'elle met en avant des
vrais gens arrivent en fait elle envoie
un message très important qui ne vous
cachez pas derrière les filtres des
réseaux sociaux et montrez vous comme
vous êtes réellement avec vos défauts
c'est très important trouve aujourd'hui
alors que honda 2 bat doit alors je suis
désolé séries c'est votre émission et
vous aussi
jesse may alors déjà je n'y croyais pas
mais alors là encore moins je pense que
les gens font ça juste pour la fame et
comme par hasard l héritière elle
n'aimait pas l'amour comme un ben non
justement
mais l'amour c'est l'amour qui ne
m'aiment pas mais cette jeune femme qui
n'a pas bouleversé la myskina
j'assume
[Applaudissements]
ce qui n'a pas rencontré jesse et la lia
les caméras ya la télé ya tout et
finalement un bâti je veux bien y aller
donc c'est un peu pour la fille mais je
n'y crois pas tellement tellement
franchement tu dis moi alors j'ai un
vrai témoignage
moi j'y croyais pas parce que je suis
quand même j'ai besoin de voir l'autre
en revanche j'ai une amie au moment qui
est tombée amoureuse qui a mené qu'à
demi une fausse photo de profil une
femme des années 60 comme ça qui parlait
sur twitter avec un mec il se sont ils
ont parlé ensemble pendant des mois et
des mois ils ne se sont jamais vus
physiquement et un jour il décide de
faire un skype ils sont tombés amoureux
non mais moi j'y crois pas c'est
impossible j'ai besoin d'avoir une
personne physique j'ai besoin je suis
plutôt qu'elle vient à dire durant la
personne ah oui c'est ma meilleure amie
ah oui oui elles mêmes par là même
quitté la france pour aller le retrouver
dans un pays européen
il s'appelle comment mary schryer sais
pas mais ça reste très rare sert à rien
d'avoir l'enveloppé corporelle de long
sera bab rabat je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui si t'as pas d' enveloppe n'a
pas de temps dit quand même qu'il y
avait un peu de faits que c'était un peu
travaillé au départ c'est à dire que en
fait cette jeune fille vous la voyez
avant est-ce que bassam en danger trois
comptes non s'il pensait pas vu avant
par contre apple là où il ya eu peut
être un truc a changé c'est que de base
c est qui me demande de venir c'est pour
moi que les mondes de venir est donc ça
c'est changer ça d'échangés après leur
sccc correspondance mais toi tu es tu
vas chez l'impression que tu étais tu as
même livré un vrai crush un mois ben moi
j'ai quelqu'un d'entier j'ai pas
sanglante il est comme on dit il n'ya
pas de mouiller sexe et août dont tes
potes dans toi non mais moi qui ai si
franchement elle a craqué pour toi ou
pas non faut demander ça va regarder
parce que c'est incroyable tous les
visites et les spectateurs se demande
bien sûr elle a peur s'ils voient là une
épée tchad
non c'est non c'est pour une raison
particulière regarder pourquoi ça moi ça
alors ça c'est bon ça non c'est pas beau
ça me fait de la peine parce que je
trouvais qu'ils allaient bien ensemble
j'aimais bien cette jeune fille oui
voilà et sa célébrité
oui mais la célébrité est minime alors
que ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
va tous finir seul comme bernard montiel
en france autant compatibles c'était un
désir ça me sert elle ces histoires
compliquées alors qu'il n'a pas commencé
c'est la pire des choses c'est d'être
avec quelqu'un et que la personne se
sentent délaissés par rapport à ses
occupations
ce que veut dire et ce soir
symboliquement on peut on va pas
repartir ensemble
c'est cool en tout cas ça fait mal mais
moi et puis le temps au moins on sait
que dans ce n'est pas la pression parce
que ni pour toi ni pour moi c'est bon
j'ai si sofia ont décidé de rester amis
incapable de faire taire ses peurs sofia
n'a pas voulu prendre le risque de
démarrer une relation amoureuse avec le
choc at avait dit quelle couleur elle
mettait de rouge à lèvres ouais c'est
pour ça que cette date en fait cette
fête se balade jamais je vous le dis
samedi à laurent delahousse qui avait
elle est très jolie ont été déçus
peut-être vu après ou pas n'ont même pas
mmorpg en contact on se parle mme après
non pas des films qui s'arrêtent de
l'amitié de l'amitié d'amitié parce que
en fait comme j'expliquais moi je veux
pas passer ma vie a raconté qu'un khin
win et inquiète pas ça va le faire c'est
d'abord s'aimer soi même se trouver
soi-même et après ce matin qu'un mission
d'aider des bd des blessures du passé
moi je suis pas médecin je sais pas mais
ça se construit l'amour quoi ça monte ça
se construit c'est là des blessures du
passé et aurait pu l'aider à à s'en
dégager
mais est trop me jessie justement par
rapport à ce que vous sembliez vivre
est-ce que vous la région juste vous
êtes un spécialiste de la mesure
le mec ça fait quand même huit ans qu'il
a demandé sa main à son mariage
au rythme où ça va je te dire attendons
vario guatémaltèque
ça oui alors oui est ce que vous n'avez
prononcer trop tôt et ce qui avait pas
une histoire avis vous lui dites est ce
que je te raccompagne aux taxis vous
n'allez pas dans la chambre et ce qu'il
fallait pas aller un peu plus loin en
faites ce que je dis c'est que moi j'ai
pas envie de m'engager dans un truc ou
promettre des choses que je peux tenir
il ya rien de pire que ça veut dire que
vous n'êtes pas ça va se passer je vais
faire ciller ça et je les tiens pas
c'est comme si en gros je me laisserais
de trois buts et trois avancées ou quoi
donc je me dis sa partie déjà pas bien
donc c'était mais c'est comme ça il faut
que tout soit faut tous les postes
soient au vert sinon ça va pas
fonctionner mais tout à fond ça va venir
tout seul si l'amour mais tais-toi
nyamwasa tonga bon tu vois sur islamabad
veut dire je connais ta réponse quand on
me dit tu as trouvé quelqu'un depuis et
qu'il a fait quoi qui samoa non ça veut
dire que c'est bon mais pas même un peu
comme comme c'est le ramadan il voulait
pas trop parler de ça mais à caen ce
soir à 22h sur un stade je mettrais si
je suis d'accord et battre eh bien oui
on en voit là bas donc il faut attendre
1 2 heure locale après neuf tout en fait
après le f'tour de ton instinct
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]